foreign
[Music]
my brother
so let's get after it and have us
go to [ __ ] bread
all right so uh I love that logo Kobo
that was taper Como did it again
he decided to react to YouTube comments
YouTubers let's get after it so ah there
it is a 516 number oh credits of course
it's a 516 number
we're gonna do this so so you're in
Nassau County so he's in [ __ ] NASA
how did I ever think he was in New York
City he feels like a Nassau accounting
guy give me some of the comments about
you I mean Gregory Ott and yeah we're
gonna get it on and I'm gonna answer
your questions and they don't all have
to be nice but let's have some decency
here huh to quote Charles Barkley man
you don't have to be an [ __ ]
but you choose to every single day in
every interaction you have
or a swisher interview Dougie Higg wants
to know how much money does George Soros
pay Chris Cuomo to foment hate in
America
let's see how much is Soros paying you
right now how much well not nothing now
he was just fired yeah are you kidding
me I've been suing him for a while now
is he paying my salary am I on Soros
shut up payroll I'll tell you what
uh I like to uh beat down the idea of a
boogeyman and that's what George Soros
is
however he did put his money behind a
lot of prosecutors uh who have some very
perverse uh extreme left views about who
should be prosecuted and what crime is
about
uh
um bit go on
based I don't trust it me neither I
gotta hear a little bit I don't trust
the son of a [ __ ] this is [ __ ] me up
I unbelievable unbelievable
um so I guess you could blame them for
that but you're allowed to use your
money as speech in this country right
that was what he's not from this country
yeah and he's not based in this country
and he's not like he has nothing to do
with this country I think I could argue
sir that people like that shouldn't be
allowed to spend a bunch of money on
their speech in this country decided
that citizens united
um it's a righty organization uh the
court said that speech is also money uh
money can be speech and that's it man we
were Off to the Races the problem or
politics isn't legal uh illegal money
it's legal money nobody is saying that
George Soros is breaking the law or that
we need to change it
what they're saying Chris you [ __ ]
stupid Guido is that it is very very
fishy and immoral to mix politics with
that
dark money is Soros uh this big bad guy
I I don't believe that I know a lot of
people who don't like him
um and there are various reasons for
that but I don't care he's not
controlling the game you're being
controlled by people who are making you
afraid of course yeah
and Klaus Schwab Koch brothers what
about Mercers what about all of them I
hate them too hold I I hate them too
that's that they always do this the Koch
brothers are [ __ ] a bunch of a bunch
of [ __ ] too like I'm sorry Chris this
isn't like
they they think this is what happens a
lot of people think they think
everyone's binary like with their
politics and their views just like they
cannot imagine anyone having a nuanced
view you know you think I'm like you I'm
not
there's a lot of big money people that
have influence in the game don't get
played for a sucker okay don't let
people tell you who to be afraid of
don't let people tell you how to think
the guy who knows to be afraid of a
virus for two years
don't be a link I chose to be afraid of
a [ __ ] uh Donald Trump I mean okay be
a free agent be independent okay be a
free agent he has the shirts huh be free
agent buy my shirt free agent yeah come
on it's a cool shirt be a critical
thinker all right your problem is not
your Sorrows it's the people who are
telling you that okay you had ah okay
cool yeah you never answered the
question no of course he didn't he just
talks in circles because they asked you
if George Charles is giving you money
and you never said no
ever given your brother money
is it governor governor of New York
hey Virgie can you see me Soros is
giving the combos any money it should be
public record no I got a great two-part
interview with Bob Costas a little while
I did this this is a comment on that so
John Griffin says so Bob bemoans the
state of the current political climate
with people attacking the man rather
than the message the person rather than
the policy and then for the next 20
minutes launches an assault on Trump the
person there is nothing wrong with Bob
Costas having an opinion about another
person he ain't running for office you
left that part out of your analysis
brother because you're a Trumper you
understand
yeah there it is
it doesn't matter if you're running for
office he Bob Costas is in the political
spheres a political commentator just
like you are that's the part where they
they they're such they're such
disingenuity this is a disingenuous
[ __ ]
understand and that's cool that's okay I
don't agree with your choice but it's
your choice Costas ain't running it's
that if he were running for office and
all he did was tell you how Trump is the
most bad businessman or a cheater or a
liar or anything else that people say
about the guy that's where it's out of
place but it literally you were you were
oh my God you [ __ ] phony piece of
[ __ ] hack all you would have on your
show were politicians that were saying
that about Trump the man
not the politician and also by the way
[ __ ] Trump so I ain't defending that guy
anymore yeah no he can suck my dick but
that's not the point you hypocritical
piece of [ __ ]
your opinions you have your opinions
about me you ever been here about
College Station you haven't been about
anybody that's where's the bird crests
it's the only thing we want to know
where's the bird
fine but it's about what the people who
are asking to be our leaders do
hey you were fired from CNN maybe you
relax
news Nation guy
oh he's so annoying
a nice Freeze Frame though but he won't
get to the bird
canceling on the left okay let's see
what this is
Ginger McIntosh this was actually a
comment on the video of your comments uh
but I think she was talking about
addressing something that you must have
brought up in that canceling that the
left mainly engages in I'm sorry are you
kidding the Uproar over a black mermaid
Banning books like to Kill a Mockingbird
arresting parents for supporting their
trans children canceling women's right
to choose I think you need to rethink
this uh uh the killer Mockingbird you
dumb stupid [ __ ]
To Kill a Mockingbird was not
Republicans that canceled To Kill a
Mockingbird it was the left that did
because of this of the black the way
they treated black people in it they
missed the point of it I remember the
story because we covered it and now you
have just these people do this to
themselves they just immediately go it
must have been the right it wasn't it
was the left I remember who it was
all right so that's [ __ ] ridiculous
all right arresting parents for
supporting their trans children what
parents are getting arrested for
supporting their trans children the ones
that are trying to save their trans
children from being trans ah okay
canceling women's rights to choose is
sir I'm sorry you can't get an abortion
to California New York anymore
uh
uh uh left the black Little Mermaid and
I'm sorry in the same way that stupid
idiot here said that you could it's okay
to go out people if you're not running
for anything I could call I can think of
black Little Mermaid stupid if I feel
like it but did I ever say Disney
shouldn't make the movie I don't care if
they make the movie yeah it's your money
to lose I don't have any Disney stock
I think that you too should rethink it
um because you are assigning blame
without looking at the precipitating
factor okay and look I'm not saying that
anybody's got the market cornered on
um going too far or in being
unreasonable
but sometimes somebody asks you a uh
Chris aren't you supposed to be in
quarantine and you try to beat them up
hey Chris but he says Fredo and you
overreact and make a scene hey Chris you
coward why don't you play our clip on
your show answer some more questions
like where's the burger where's the bird
where's the bucket the bird
left stands two things can be true at
once the things you point out are bad
and it can be that they're precipitated
by things sometimes that are bad uh for
instance lgbtq
um and the expanding vocabulary by the
way nobody has called people [ __ ] and
fairies more than Chris Cuomo he's a
guido I know plenty of guidos and if
you're gonna tell me these two guys
weren't always making fun of the making
fun of the mo who's that you're [ __ ]
nuts are you kidding me I wouldn't be
surprised if this brother threw rocks at
the queers let's not pretend let's get
out of dump Guido
right in the expanding reality of
diversity
so it's not always so the short answer
on Soros money yeah yes the long answer
I'm gonna need some string and thumb
tacks got it fair enough
it's it's a lot an easy sell
um too bad I don't have to sell it well
you do if you want acceptance you live
your own life you live it the way you
want and the way you think is right you
identify the way you want that's fine
but do well here don't worry Virgie you
don't need you don't need a string in
anything
you mean something like this
yeah pretty much okay well there you go
something like that
okay that's yeah
you saw Chris can you address that yeah
that'd be great Chris okay some kind of
Boogeyman or some [ __ ]